[Music]
recruiters work
work for clients
we work exclusively for clients but we
have this kind of odd three-party
symbiotic relationship it's completely
unique in professional service
representation where
we get paid by one
side of a transaction
but have to be perceived as fair
balanced and delivering value to both
sides
lawyers don't get that i mean you got
you got two companies fighting with each
other company a's got a lawyer company
b's got a lawyer the lawyers fight with
each other but they know who they're
they know who they're representing
they're not trying to be fair they're
advocates they're advocates for their
side you know marketing people pr people
you know accountants they're working for
their clients and every client has one
of those but the search the search
profession is is pretty odd
so
the people that do would have to tread
this line between loyalty to a client
and respect and loyalty among the
candidates because unless they can put a
transaction together
with two willing parties who are both
smart and ideally not going to do
something that's not in the both of
their best interests
no transaction happens no search gets
completed and
nothing gets done and that person
doesn't stay in the business very long
so you can make that work for you
as long as you understand
that it's not the recruiter's job to
find you your next position it's a
recruiter's job
to solve the problem that their client
has and if you can be the solution to
that problem then they're going to be
real happy to bring you forward
and have you be a candidate for that
project if you're not the solution to
that problem
two things can happen if you recognize
it early on and raise your hand and say
this isn't right for me what i'm really
interested in is x
uh let me try to help you with a
suggestion of somebody better than me
for this project and would you remember
me for something or introduce me to one
of your colleagues who's working on what
i want to do that's a good interaction
that will serve you well
what won't serve you well is either
trying to convince a recruiter any
recruiter really at any level that
you're something that you're not because
they'll figure it out eventually or that
you
are interested in something that in the
end you're really not interested in
because you're wasting the recruiters
time which is the only asset they have
to make a living with and they don't
appreciate it when their time's wasted
uh they know every every uh set of
interactions is not gonna lead to a
successful outcome and you may go all
the way to the end and you may decide or
the client may decide this isn't right
it didn't happen but as long as that was
done with good faith nobody has any hard
feelings but if it was done with bad
faith
and bad faith can be on the client side
too i've experienced this as well in
which case i apologize to the cli to the
to the candidates and try to make it
right if i can but
nobody worries about that as long as
everybody is proceeding
uh along the path with good faith
recruiters when they do searches use a
variety of techniques one they all have
databases of candidates that they that
they maintain not not so much from
resumes sent to them but by profiles
they've created over the years
candidates they've interviewed maybe
presented and want to do present again
because that's
they've got qualified people so they
look at that that's all categorized they
they look at their own
uh prior search work that's similar
where did we do a search like this the
last time and who were the candidates
who came in second third fourth on on
that search that maybe would be a good
fit for this they do industry sourcing
which is what you talked about where
they call around typically at a level or
two above
what they're what they're trying to find
if if i'm doing a search for a marketing
you know vp
uh i'm calling ceos and saying you know
who who are the best marketing people
you know
and your competitors uh you know maybe
not one of your people sometimes they'll
even suggest one of their people that
is is blocked
you know surprisingly it happens
um
who who's worked for you over the years
that you think is really good
and here this is where if you've worked
for really strong mentors and strong
performers they know about you and if
you stay in touch with them as even if
they've moved on from where you are
they'll think about you they'll
recommend you because they're the people
with the reputations who are going to
get the calls the weak ones don't get
those calls the strong ones get those
calls and are in a position to help
influence the hiring of people that
either they know about or more likely
have worked for them or for their on
their teams over the years and really
good executives i find tend to
take very good care
of people who've performed for them over
the years i mean they'll recommend them
for for jobs they'll proactively
recommend them for jobs and in fact if
you've got a good relationship with them
you can go ask them to do that go to
somebody who was a boss of yours in
another company if that was a good
relationship he or she has a good
feeling for you call them and say
look you know i'm i'm ready to make a
move who should i be talking to who in
the search firm world do you know
that you'd be willing to introduce
me to and if somebody reaches out to you
you know
keep me in line be specific be special
try to be very clear
when you're dealing with recruiters of
any kind what it is that you want what
you're willing to do what you're not
willing to do and you know be asked ask
the kind of questions to try to decide
if this opportunity that they've put in
front of you or called you about
is is the right potential one for you if
it is say so don't be cute don't play
hard to get
be honest and be plenty of time for
negotiation at the end
if it isn't pull out fast and and don't
waste their time
don't lie
or embellish
your resume my colleagues and i spent
years
honing skills to smell coming a
mile away i mean a good recruiter will
not let you get away
with claiming something
that isn't true
that's fluffy credit for something that
really maybe you had a small part of and
you're trying to take too much credit
for you don't need to do that you've got
good records just be honest and and try
to position yourself someplace where
your
skill set and your interests fit what
the clients need needs
i've covered some of this other stuff
the second one though i want to come
back to because as you think about what
it is that you want to do there is a
role there for executive recruiters to
play over a long period in your career
and the key i think for all of you is to
figure out literally that handful
and it's probably no more than that in
any particular geography if you go more
broadly global it could be a little more
it's still not a big number
and i doubt i doubt for most of you
the
critical mass of recruiters among the
major search firms who would be in a
position to be really good
career
long
allies and sources for you i would be
very surprised if that was more than 10
or 12
people in total
that's a number of people that you can
over time get to know
it's not hundreds that's hard but you
know 10
6 8 10 12. you can do that
particularly if you identify who they
are and have a strategy to get to know
them in a positive way through
introductions of people other search
people others who will help you but get
to know them in a positive way stay
connected don't be a pain in the neck
but stay connected and and build a very
long-term relationship with them
particularly the ones that are working
in your chosen field
a level or two above where you are now
because over time they'll move up too
and as you move up you'll be heading
into there into their space
from from below as as it will and those
are the people you want to be dealing
with not the ones that are working at or
below your level now which by the time
you get your next promotion you've
outgrown them and they can't help you
anymore so
you want to be aiming high
it starts by figuring out what it is
that you want to do
and and being as clear and specific
about that as you can and then you get
to people in the recruiting firms and
there's five large ones large global
ones mine was one and then there's you
know a dozen or so mid-tier ones and
then lots of small ones many of whom are
uh founded and staffed by alums of the
big ones so they're just the quality's
just as good they may be they may be
small
you start asking people around who does
this kind of work
and you ask enough questions the same
names will come up
second way to do it is
reverse engineer searches that got done
if there's a job out there that
you
would like to have had or would like to
have
the next time
and it just got filled you saw the
announcement in the paper chances are
there was a recruiter that did that
search call up the company call up the
individual in the job and say look i see
you got this promotion or sent him an
email
you can reach him on linkedin by the way
we'll come back to that
and say i'm curious as to was there a
recruiter that handled this search and
if so who was it
and did were they good
because if they were good for them
they'll be good for you the one thing
about the recruiting profession is once
you start building a reputation for
doing certain kinds of searches
the industry knows
and they'll come back to the same people
time and time again for those projects
that's why they that's how they build
specializations and
the same thing happens within the search
firms
i got a lot of calls because i was high
profile from companies wanting searches
done
almost never would i do them so the
question would be who would we recommend
that they talk to
and it's going to be the person in our
firm
that has the best track record doing
those kinds of searches and everybody
knows who they are
and so at that point your goal is to
figure out who those people are
and
try to get an opportunity to
have them know who you are
and if they're willing just spend a
little bit of time not a lot of time but
you know 15 20 minutes meeting you
and uh and just saying yeah maybe maybe
i'm not a candidate
for anything right now but i'm a
candidate for what you do as a recruiter
and one of these days you're going to
have an assignment that i'm going to be
qualified for and interested in i wanted
you to know who i was
and that are that that line of
um discussion works if you're right if
your facts are right and you've done
your homework
it's a waste of time
if it's if it's a random
blast at
the recruiting world
and just as it's pretty much a waste of
time to send resumes to recruiting firms
don't bother it's not worth the paper
you're printing your resumes on they get
tens of thousands most of them
unfortunately go in the go in the scrap
heap including some of the very same
people
who come into them through their
sourcing
exercises
later on a search that they pay a lot of
attention to they wouldn't have paid any
attention to the resume coming in
because they're not geared
to do the scan and match
by the way
linkedin
is
an excellent way i mean linkedin didn't
exist for most of the years my years in
the recruiting business the search firms
are using linkedin now massively and so
you know you need to make sure that your
linkedin profile is current and is as as
good as it can be
and if you want to get to somebody a
recruiter or somebody that you don't
know
and you don't know what their email
address is if they have a linkedin
account you can send them a linkedin
mail
on the linkedin account and they'll get
it it's it's the best way to reach
somebody that you don't know how to
reach
[Music]